Okay. Yeah, I remember Issa. Yeah.
Welcome back, bro. What's up, guys? How
you doing? What's up? Doing good, man.
How you doing? So, so we're asking
Muslims if you guys have a verse in
chapter 3 specifically that says that
the either the scriptures have been
corrupted or a verse that says that the
Quran only confirms part of the
scripture while others is corrupted or
maybe that you can only believe in
certain parts of the scripture while
rejecting the other parts. Is there a
verse that exists like that in chapter 3
to your knowledge? I don't think
explicitly. I think it points to it. I
think the uh correct interpretation of a
couple of these verses points to what
you're saying. Is this surah 3, by the
way, or are you talking about other
chapters of the Quran? Yeah. 33 and then
I think he said 37. Okay. Right. That's
interesting. Should we get those up? 33
and 31. 78. 78. Oh, 378. Yeah. Make it
make it make it 3 to make it 3 three to
four and then 78. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So,
by the way, uh just people were asking
this as well. We were actually on 378
earlier. So, everyone was asking in the
chat, what commentary were we looking
at? It was Imm Catheter 3:78. And that's
where we're reading from earlier where
Abbas uh states that none of Allah's
words are changed. That's right. That's
right. That's right. So, do you want to
go through one by one or what's your
plan? Yeah. Yeah, let's get let's get
chapter 3:3 and 4 up so that we can all
see it for the edification of the room
and then uh Yeah. And let uh Yeah. So,
yeah, pull that up. Let Isa explain how
he's reading it cuz he's he's reading it
differently than than we would read it.
So, let's see what he's saying. So, we
believe that the Quran is the kind of
filter for knowledge. Obviously you guys
know that about us when so with this
issue I I've noticed a pattern that
within the next couple of pages or most
of the time the next page after it's
making after it's um saying something
about the people of the book distorting
the scripture or the previous scriptures
or affirming them it kind of clarifies
the Quran clarifies like within that
page or within the next page exactly
what it's talking about like with this
one 378 there are some among them who
distort the book with their tongues to
make you think this is distortion from
the book but it is not what the book
says they say it is from God but it is
not from God and so they attribute lies
to God knowingly okay so let's let's
break this down a little bit Issa so we
see in chapter 3 verse verse 3 and 4 it
acknowledges that it ca the Quran comes
confirming the Torah and the gospel that
is guidance and light for mankind right
so it came down confirming the Torah and
the gospel saying that the Torah and
gospel is true. We get over to verse 78
and it talks about how people distort
the book with their tongues. They're
lying about what the book says, saying
things that God never said and they're
applying these words to to God. Right. I
I believe there's a interpretation about
the oral transmission of the Torah in
this verse as well. So like so ju so
just to be clear this verse is not
saying that the scripture is textually
corrupted but that people are lying
about what their scriptures actually say
right well because the Torah was
originally oral transmission it would be
saying that there are corruptions done
to that with the tongue and then there
like you well it can't it can't it can't
possibly mean that if you're trying to
go to some No can't if you're trying to
go back to some uh pre-written version
of the Torah where it was transmitted
orally. I mean, keep in mind even even
in the Torah itself, it talks about
writing these things down. But suppose
you had just some oral transmission of
the Torah. The Quran says that they
distort these things knowingly, which
means that it's that they they're not
learning uh they're not learning
everything from a corrupted version of
the Torah. If they did, they would think
that's the word of God and they would do
so and they would be ignorant of what
the Torah originally said. So the fact
that they do so knowingly is basically
the the general condemnation in the
Quran of the Jews and Christians. It's
that we have our scriptures, but back
then but back then most people couldn't
read. And so the person who could read
from the scriptures had sort of power
over other people to uh kind of uh
control what they believe. So if you
wanted to if you wanted to convince your
listeners that the Torah or the Gospels
say something different from from what
they say, you could just read you could
just be reading a part and then add a
few add a few thoughts to it, add words
here and there, move things around, take
things out of order and stuff like that.
You could do that and people didn't know
because they can't they couldn't read
for themselves, right? And so that's
that's sort of the general the general
criticism of what Jews and Christians
are doing when they disagree with Islam.
It's not that we have a different text.
It's that the speaker, the reader does
so knowingly and he knowingly distorts
what the text says to people and they
don't know any better. Okay. I I would
agree with that. That's the ma that is
the probably that's the interpretation
that I would go with and most people
would go with. I would agree with that.
So that would leave I I know J y'all
want to jump in just I just want to make
sure we understand this point here. So
this would leave the fact that the Torah
and the Gospel textually like the the
actual text is actually good. It's not
messed with, just that people are lying
about what they say, right? Yeah. Um,
the Quran says about the Torah, the
book. So, it can't be oral. It says the
book. And also, by the way, the book
that's it is the book that is read,
right? In chapter 10 vers in chapter 10
verse 94, it says it's read. And then 7
verse 157 says it's written. And if you
go to the comments here for chapter 5
verse 45, it actually says specifically,
yeah, specifically he says they have the
text of the Torah,
like the written text. Yeah, we've got
the Arabic if you've got an Arab friend
or something as well. It actually says
the word text and then they it says they
deviate from the ruling of the Torah
stated in their text. Okay, about that's
about the adulterer. Muhammad had a case
where the Jews came to him because
someone committed adultery. And if you
read that story, the Jews wanted to to
hide the the verse in the book. So that
means there's a book and there's a verse
in that book and they put the hand they
physically covered it with their hand.
They physically covered it with their
hand and Muhammad said, "Stop doing
that. Read the book. Bring the book." So
you again, what verse are you
referencing right now? That's chapter 5
verse 45. And then and then the other
references was chapter 10 verse 94 and
chapter 7 verse 157. It's written. It's
read. 545 first. Um 54. Let's go to 545.
You guys are you guys are cheating by
the way. Just letting you know. Now
you're Now you're in chapter 5. See, we
can go back to chapter 3. That's what I
was planning on. No, no, not you, Issa.
That I'm talking about giant DLC. They
just he's just teasing. He's just women
the women just go off
and
expect. Yeah, maybe he says something. I
don't know. I said the women just go off
on a tangent and we're all Who? Which
women? What? What? He's joking. He's
joking. He's joking. Oh, he's trying.
You're trying to be funny. Oh, you're
trying to be funny. He was piggybacking
off my joke, guys. So, let me get
anywhere. So, 5:45 like what I'm
noticing the pattern I'm noticing with
you guys uh not with you guys, but with
this issue is that following s uh
following verses kind of refute it. So
after 5:45 you have 46 47 then 48 says
we reveal to you oh prophet this book
with the truth as a confirmation of
previous scriptures and a supreme
authority on them. So like can you keep
reading can you keep reading if you
don't mind judge between them what God
has revealed and do not follow their
desires over the truth that has come to
you to each of you we have ordained a
code of law and a way of life. If God w
you one community but his will is to
test you with what he has given of uh
what he has given each of you. So
compete with one another in doing good.
To God you will all return and then he
will inform you of the truth regarding
your differences. Okay. So what are they
being told to to do with regarding to
race to the good? Raise to the good.
Probably believe in the prophet
revealing this because it says that in
the beginning of this this section of
the uh of the ver of the surah. Well, he
also said that if he wanted to, he could
have made you one community. Yes. Yes.
And you'll see that also being
translated as one religion. But he's
made you many communities. In other
words, there's Jews, there's Christians,
and now there's the believers who follow
Muhammad. But he's saying just race to
the good. So how's that possible? He he
starts the verse off by saying, okay,
there is this book that is being sent.
We reveal to you the prophet this book
with the truth as a confirmation of
previous scriptures and as a supreme
authority over them. So judge between
them. What is the the judge between
them? the previous scriptures. I'm
guessing where where are you? Okay, you
you're going to think it's the previous
scriptures. I have a different way of
looking at that. By what Allah has
revealed and do not follow their
desires. So I'm saying no no the them is
the people because it qualifies the the
following part of the the verse. So it
starts off by saying so judge between
them by what Allah has revealed and do
not follow their desires. So in other
words, it's saying judge between the
people. So if you have a Jew and you
have a Christian and they're arguing
about whether Abraham was a Jew or
whether Abraham was a Christian, which
is another verse in the Quran, you can
basically say, "Well, hang on. I have
this Quran. I can use this to settle
this dispute as a supreme authority to
judge between the Christian and the
Jew." But he doesn't say anything about
their scriptures. It's just telling you,
"Hey, there might be Jews and Christians
arguing about theology, but you can use
the Quran as a way of saying, I'll
settle that dispute." I don't believe
that that's the the dominant. Do you
understand why I would come to that
though based on the fact that it says
judge between them and then it says do
not follow their desires there is is the
people right so who's it telling you to
judge either the book or the people it
could be it seems to be the people no I
think it's the book man I think that's
what the the dominantation is I think uh
so okay uh you know Muhammad said that
the reason why you need two women to be
worthy for one witness is because one
might forget something the other one
needs to remind it so just to remind you
maybe you need a woman to remind you of
this. But the reason why we went here
was to show you the text that the text
was written. It was written text. It's
not oral. So that's that's the point
that we were going on. So why you went
on to 48 and started talking about what
that I don't know what's how it's
related. Chapter 7 chapter 7 vers1. No,
no. Cuz we're not you're not clarifying
that it's written or oral. You're trying
to make another point. So the point is
is that chapter 10 verse 94, chapter 7
verse 157, and chapter 5:45 all teach
that it's read, it's written, and it's a
physical text. So it's not some oral
thing that existed during Moses' time
that doesn't exist in Muhammad's time.
It's something that's written, read,
it's recited, and it's a text. And the
reason he wanted it to be oral and not
text because the verse that he went to
378 said they change it with their
mouth. That's the point. Whatever they
changed it was the mouth. The text was
fine. And if you go to the of that surah
378, your initial one, you see
uh Abbas and uh the scholars, lots of
other scholars saying no one can change
the words of Allah, meaning the text.
What they changed was the
interpretation. That was our point is
that the Torah was a text and that it
was all preserved. What people changed
was the text. Well, sorry, was the the
Well, it's as important as the text
because if you have text that is
interpreted incorrectly, then you guys
know as well as I do, Muslim extremists,
Christians, extremist. If you have a
text that is not being interpreted in
its correct historical context, it's the
text is almost worthless really because
you can have you have people who
interpret it correctly. Surah 3 verse
1999 Allah himself says there are group
of people following the scripture which
means us the people of the book who
follow it who follow it correctly and
they don't exchange it for a small price
go to surah 3 verse 1999 now you will
see that Allah actually says no there's
a group of them that actually do
preserve it that actually do recite it
correctly so no just because someone
interprets something wrong doesn't mean
there's a group that doesn't interpret
it right what what uh what group of
Christians andor or Jews would you say
most closely resemble Islamic practices
probably. Yeah. So this is the problem
with your Quran. Your your Quran is the
one stating this. So now you're asking
us the the reality of this whether this
is true or not. Well, you're disputing
with your Quran. We didn't write your
Quran. We're telling you what it says
though. Yeah. We don't agree. So the
Quran says that there's some that don't
sell the book. They don't corrupt the
book whether by alterations and meaning
or interpretations or whatever, but
they're being truthful and they recite
it truthfully. So the Quran is stating
that there's a text, the Bible existing
Muhammad's time that people are
accurately following it and practicing
it. And Allah is also compelling them to
do that. He said, "I'm going to judge by
it, to follow it, to recite it in the
way that it should be." Yeah. So there
there's no getting around this. But just
so you know, Isa, as well, there just
and to answer what you said, there is
cuz I think I know what you're thinking
here. There is no Christian or Jewish
group that correlates with the Islamic
belief in a way that is is the same or
without heresy or without some form of
Islamic blasphemy. There just isn't that
group. It doesn't exist. Of course,
that's true. So, this is the Islamic
dilemma. Yeah. So, this is the Islamic
dilemma. This is the Islamic dilemma,
but I believe the Quran clarifies it
right after all the verses you guys
quote for it to it doesn't. It doesn't.
So, what verse? Because we already went
over 378. So what verse beginning of
three let's go three three he has
revealed to you prophet the book in
truth confirming what came before it as
you so so let's be clear what it
actually says in the Arabic it says
between his hands so in his possession
so it's not talking about something when
you say what came before it it's it's
only a bad translation if you don't
understand what's actually being said
because it's not saying something in the
distant past that doesn't exist today.
It's saying that yes it was before it
but it's also saying this is in their
possession today. So, I don't know how
this helps your case. It actually makes
worse for you. Yeah, it says before.
Yeah, it's like it's it's like it's like
our word English. I, you know, you can
say before and you can mean in time or
you can say before like I stand here
before you. That means in the present
and I'm right in front of you. They
translate it as before it but means it's
it's it's there. It's between its hands.
It's it's in its presence. So, it's
still there. And you can find Islamic
scholars that agree with that as well.
Like this isn't a fringe thing. This is
don't though as well. And you guys you
guys Well, yeah. I mean that's that's
because there's there's reasons as to
why Muslim scholars in the Sunni
tradition in the modern period have to
do that because if they don't do stuff
like that it gets a little too close to
admitting the Islamic dilemma is true
and that's why there's all these weird
interpretations of verses where actually
you look at the Quran holistically it it
seems like crazy remember according to
like the da guys today they want you to
believe that you can take parts of the
Torah parts of the and reject other
parts Even though the Quran explicitly
tells you not to do that, otherwise
you'll be among the losers. Like that's
how far this has gone from our paradigm.
Like we're just looking at this as
people who are not Muslims. We're just
reading the Quran. We're taking notes.
We're marking where these verses affirm
the previous scriptures and where they
supposedly say they've been corrupted.
And we're saying, "Wow, overwhelmingly
it's saying it's been affirmed." The
inspiration, preservation, and authority
are overwhelmingly preserved in the
Quran. Like look, it just keeps talking
about it. The Quran loves talking about
our previous scriptures. It thinks
they're great. It thinks that Muhammad
is in there.
You know, like why would why would Muham
Okay, so think of it this way. Why would
Muhammad who is getting this revelation
from Allah from the Islamic paradigm?
Why would he tell Christians and Jews,
hey, you need to believe in me? And the
reason you should believe in me is
because I am another prophet like the
previous prophets like Abra Abraham,
Mosa, Isa. I'm just another prophet. And
because you accept what they say in
their scriptures, you need to accept me
cuz I'm in that same tradition. I'm just
another prophet. Why would he say that
over and over again in the Quran? That's
a massive theme in the Quran. And then
say, "Oh, actually, yeah, that the Torah
and the angel have kind of been
corrupted, though. You know, you guys
have all this stuff about Jesus being
God in the Gospels. It's kind of a bit
awkward." You know, I wasn't really
talking about that part. I was talking
about this other part. Oh, by the way,
don't take parts of the Torah or the
Injil or previous scriptures because
then you'll go to hell. Like, you
understand? In effect, you're you're
downplaying the Quran's own argument.
We're actually understanding the Quran
and the point the Quran is trying to
make holistically. It's a very concise
argument, and it's made over and over
again, but you're underplaying that by
saying, "Actually, the Quran doesn't
know what it's talking about. The
previous scriptures have been
corrupted." Okay. Well, I'm going to
answer with the Quran because you just
went on for a while. Appreciate that.
Good. Good. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The one
who has revealed to you, oh prophet, the
book of which some verses are precise.
They are the foundation of the book,
while others are elusive. Those with
deviant hearts follow the elusive
verses, seeking to spread doubt through
their false
interpretations, guys. But none grasps
their full meaning except God. As for
those well-grounded in knowledge, they
say, "We believe in this Quran. It is
all from our Lord." But none will be
mindful of this except people of reason.
That is a couple verses after the one
you just quoted saying, "Oh, it confirms
everything in our book." So that's Do
you know what you've just done? You've
just proven my point. I just told you
that we've been studying the Quran,
going through chapter by chapter list. I
have a spreadsheet of all the verses
that talk about the previous scriptures
and like they're like 99% positive with
like slight ambiguity at best in 279 and
we've dealt with that. That's the best
you have. Whereas you just quoted 3:7
which again a very well-known verse to
uh to Muslims which basically says look
there's the clear verses and there's the
unclear verses. What you're doing is
you're appealing to the unclear verses.
You went to 548 and tried to have a
particular understanding of Muayan. Is
that clear or is that unclear? Well,
scholars disagree on what the word
means. So it kind of seems like you've
pointed to an unclear verse. What about
all the verses we pointed to? Surah 33.
Is that clear? I very unclear bro. very
unclear. No, it's not 43 is unclear. Are
you really? Hey, what one sec? One
second. Let let me just uh let me let me
just explain the the sort of background
of uh of uh 37 here. So, some Quran
verses. Some Quran verses real quick.
Surah 11:1. This is a book whose verses
have been made firm and free from
imperfection and then they have been
expounded in detail. 12:1 These are
verses of the clear book. 15:1 These are
the verses of the book and of a Quran
that makes things clear. 2446 Certainly
we have revealed clear communications.
262 These are the verses of the book
that makes things clear. 271 These are
verses of the Quran, a book that makes
things clear. 28:2 These are verses of
the book that makes things clear. 579 He
it is who sends down clear
communications upon his servant that he
may bring you forth from utter darkness
into light. So the Quran for years is
bragging about how clear it is. Allah
had all eternity to get the Quran to say
exactly what he wants so that it's
perfectly clear. Then you eventually
ended up with a Christian community who
came to visit Muhammad and they started
asking questions. Why is Allah referring
to himself as we? These were Arabic
speaking Christians and they were not
familiar with the plural of majesty as
Muslims would eventually try to uh
explain the use of plural pronouns. So
they're asking him things like they're
asking him questions. Hey, wait a
minute. Do you know what this means? Do
you know what it means for Jesus to be
the word of God? Do you know what these
things mean? And that's that's what
surah 3:7 is answering. It's answering
these Christians who came and ask
questions about, hey, do you not do you
not understand all these things that
that you're incorporating from uh from
from the teachings of Christianity that
actually imply the deity of Christ? What
what are you doing here? Allah's
response is, "Oh yeah, yeah, some verses
of the Quran are clear. Other verses,
you know, these are just beyond
understanding." He's responding to
Christians who are using these passages
to defend Christian theology. But it's
interesting Muslim commentators when
they try to reconcile these the Quran
saying over and over and over again like
a beating drum that it's clear, it's
clear, it's clear, it's clear, it's
clear with all of the sudden 37 in
response to a group of Christians
wreaking havoc on Muhammad saying, "Oh,
it's actually there parts that are
unclear." They reconciled this. The way
they reconciled this is, yeah, there are
theological claims and theological
issues that are just beyond your
understanding. Those are only going to
be understood by Allah. You guys can't
understand them. However, what Allah is
perfectly clear on. When it when the
Quran says that these things are
perfectly clear, that's referring to
Allah's commands. Allah's commands are
always perfectly clear. Well, guess
what? Jews and Jews, you judge by the
Torah. That is a command. That is
perfectly clear. Christians, you judge
by the gospel. That is a command. It has
to be by definition perfectly clear. Uh
Jews and Christians, people of the book,
you have no ground to stand upon unless
you stand fast by the Torah, the gospel,
and all the revelation that has come to
you. That is a command that has to be
perfectly clear. So if you're applying
37 to say that we're that we're
misinterpreting these verses about uh
the status of our scriptures and what
we're supposed to do with them, that's
outside that's outside of that. This
doesn't include commands. Yeah. What he
said. And also why would you gaslight me
if you're not being clear? Like Isa
saying the unclear versus those who
hearts have deviated don't understand.
If you're unclear, you can't blame the
person listening.
for not understanding. Do you see what
I'm saying? Like if I'm being unclear to
you now, I can't say your heart has
deviated because I'm unclear. So that's
why you don't understand. It's Allah's
Is that a good point? It's Allah's
point. It's Allah's fault. He should
have made it clear. But Allah blames the
people. Allah makes it unclear and then
he blames the people saying your hearts
are deviated because otherwise you would
have understood my unclearness. Have you
seen Don't you believe the same thing
about the Bible? Have you Have you seen
any more gaslighting than this? No.
Don't you guys believe the same exact
thing? No, I we don't because there's no
not one verse in my Bible says to me, I
blame you for being unclear myself. So,
there's nothing there's nothing in the
Bible that says there's verses that are
clear and unclear or God is is is saying
that every verse in the Quran is clear
or in the Bible is clear and then
blaming people for mis misusing parts
where God was unclear. Now, there's
there's stuff that's clear. There's
stuff that's unclear. It's ambiguous up
for interpretation. The Bible never
makes it clear of ultimate clearness.
And I I just want to be I just want to
be clear on something. So, we've been
doing this thing called the Islamic
Dilemma Project where we go through the
entire Quran with a group of people
going over it verse by verse trying to
find every single passage that relates
to the Islamic dilemma in some way,
whether it's positive or negative. And
we haven't found anything negative yet.
But one thing that we are doing is going
through verse by verse that does talk
about the Islamic dilemma. And we're
going through the commentaries very
carefully. Guess what? No commentator,
we're we're on chapter 5 right now and
we just finished translating the rest
for chapter 5. No commentator ever
applies chapter 3:7 to any of the verses
that we appeal to. They never say, "Oh,
this is an unclear verse." Only Allah
knows the real interpretation of this
verse. There's not a single commentary
that we've and we're going through it.
We're going through multiple
commentaries. None of them say what
you're saying. Chapter 3:3. Oh, that's
an unclear verse. So isn't it funny that
no Muslim commentator for all these
years has ever said hundreds of years by
the way ever said that chapter 3:3 is
unclear and you're coming up today
because you're being pressed with the
Islamic dilemma and now all of a sudden
the miracle of reinterpretation oh it's
unclear it's called I'll trust me bro
which is and other Muslims that come up
with these crazy things that we've never
seen in Islamic tradition and they've
been reading the Quran for 1400 years.
Let's see I want to hear what he thinks
about that. Issa, what what do you think
about that? That, you know, no Islamic
commentator applies 3:7 about unclear
verses to verses that say the Quran
confirms the previous scriptures. What
What do you think about that? He's the
one who has revealed you a prophet. I'm
a little lost with the filibustering,
guys. Like I mean, yeah. Yeah, that's
why I I just kept it simple. So, what
basically what he said is is that no
scholar that they're going through the
verses looking up the commentaries.
Yeah. None of the commentaries ever
apply chapter 3:7, right, about unclear
verses to the verses that talk about the
confirmation of the Torah and the
Gospel. They never say that those are
the verses that are unclear or those are
some of the verses that are unclear. You
know what I'm saying? Yeah. Yeah. I
would I just thought it pertained to
because I feel like I've been reading
over it while you guys are doing this.
I've been reading through the Quran. I'm
a busy I'm a busy dude. I work a lot.
But um I've been I've been reading
through these these verses that you guys
are talking about and it seems like the
Quran like has the answer at least in my
the way I see things has the answer for
you guys in the next couple. So what
what is the answer that the Quran gives
for this Islamic dilemma? So the the
dilemma is the Quran says that the Torah
and the Gospel, the previous scriptures
are with the Jews and Christians.
They're preserved. They're
authoritative, right? And they are good
for use. You're saying that the Quran
answers this. So what? All right. Go
ahead. So in chapter three, where does
the Quran answer this? Okay. So another
uh you guys used 33. You guys also used
uh spoke earlier about 378, right? That
was you actually, but yeah, we can speak
about them if you like. Just to say
though, if you're leaving 33, I'm just
going to say that that means that you
don't actually find anything that helps
you there. That 33 is clear and it does
say what we are saying. It says it does
confirm the previous scriptures as being
a source of guidance and being sent by
Allah. But it also says right after that
that it alludes to the fact that being
ultimately guided is believing in this
Quran. It says it over and over again.
Explain what does the Quran do? The
Quran is the thing one that tells you
that they're not corrupted. So you're
not believing in the Quran. Yeah.
Exactly. So you're in you're in a corner
because the Quran says the Quran says
believe me, right? The Quran said you
must believe me. And the Quran also says
you I I confirmed the previous
scripture. So you but then you say the
scripture is corrupted. The the Quran is
telling them look you you can know that
Muhammad is a real prophet because he is
agreeing with the previous scriptures.
So it's not only as if the Quran is just
arbitrarily saying yeah I agree with the
previous scriptures for the sake of it.
It makes arguments based off this. And
if you undermine that you're undermining
your own Quran. Do you understand what
you're doing? Yeah. No, I don't agree
with your interpretations of these
things, bro. That's not That's not my
Okay,
look, I can quote you tons of scholars
that say, actually, it's basically all
Sunni scholars like 7157, what's the
commentary on that? It's going to tell
you, yeah, we believe that at the time
of Muhammad, the Jews actually had and
the Christians had in their scriptures
at all in the a written description of
Muhammad. 37. The answer is we just
answered just just answered you call
from our Lord but none will be mindful
of this except people of reason. It just
really quickly sir how does how does 37
I want to hear you out. How does 37
answer the Islamic dilemma that the
Quran says it confirms the previous
scriptures and that we are to judge by
them and that they're true? How does 37
relate to that? Because we all because
Muslims believe the Quran is a forcon,
right? A Christ. I do not Issa. I'm not
I don't mean to is a forcon. Yeah,
exactly. But I don't I don't mean to cut
you off. I do not care what Muslims
believe. Dude, dude, listen. Listen. I
don't care what Muslims believe. I only
care because you said you're going to
speak from the Quran. So, I'm giving you
this chance. Okay. Go ahead. How does
chapter 3:7 relate to the Torah and the
Gospel being confirmed by the Quran and
said that it's true? How does
37 answer or deal with that? Because
it's saying as for those well-grounded
in knowledge, they say we believe in
this Quran. It's very explicit in front
of But you're not saying that though.
You're saying you don't believe in the
Quran. Yeah, that's what we're pointing
out. You don't Allah Allah over and over
and over again, he affirms our
scriptures and you're saying you don't
believe that he's affirming our
scriptures. So you're that you're on the
receiving end of that verse. That verse
is condemning you. Yes. Totally. Yes.
The verse is condemning me. the person
who believes in God. You're being you're
being sarcastic. You're saying that
you're saying that we're quoting the
Quran to and you're saying uh Allah says
no one can change his words. And you're
saying, "Yeah, his words were changed."
Allah says, "Judge by the gospel." Don't
judge by the gospel. It's been
corrupted. Judge by the Torah. Don't
judge by the Torah. It's been corrupted.
Christians have no ground to stand upon
unless they stand fast by the Torah and
the Gospel. You say, "No, don't don't do
that. Your books have been corrupted."
You're saying the opposite on dozens of
verse, dozens of Quran verses. Allah
says something and you say, "No, he
means the opposite." And we say, "What
are you talking about? It's as clear as
day." And then you go 37. No, that's
that's the unclear stuff. And then we
point out to you, no Muslim has ever
said these verses are the unclear stuff
that Surah 3:7 is referring to. And so
you you're just you basically are the
one to discover all of this for
yourself. And we pointed out the
historical background. The historical
background was on theological matters
where where Christians were pointing
out, Muhammad, you keep adopting these
things that you hear from Christians
into your scriptures and they make no
sense because these point to the deity
of Christ. And that's when he has to
say, "Oh, yeah, these are theological
matters. We can't understand these kinds
of verses." He's not talking about
verses that are that are approving the
previous scriptures. Surah 3, at least
the beginning parts are a response to
this Christian group. And the response
to the Christian group is yes, Allah
sent down your scripture and Allah sends
down the Quran. Yes, these are as good
as gold. But in the Quran, these things
you're pointing to for these theological
issues, yeah, these are just these are
just beyond our comprehension. That
doesn't change the fact that he in the
midst of his response to the Jews and
Christians, he says, "Yes, I'm affirming
your scriptures." And you're somehow
saying, "No, no, no, he's not affirming
their scriptures." Which would mean
which would mean that you're the one
who's not following the scriptures. It's
a weird situation where we once again
have more respect for your book that we
reject than than you do and you believe
in it. No, that's because you're all
misinterpreting this wrong. And I'm
sorry I can't guide you. Sorry you can't
guide me. Or my friend, it looks like
we're we can bring receipts, but you're
not being able to bring receipts. You're
just saying everything's unclear. Avery
asked me to answer from the Quran and I
said couple verses down it says we
believe like the ones of knowledge say
we believe in what is wrong with you
what seriously what is wrong with you
what does chapter 3 verse 7 have to do
with what we're talking about that's
what I've been asking I haven't heard an
answer to that
because show my screen can we go to the
next verse in chapter no this verse bro
this verse what does 37 have to do with
what we're talking about because it's I
don't know how I can make make it any
clearer, man. Maybe ask Allah, bro.
Yeah. Hey guys, it's funny cuz uh I uh I
highlighted every single verse in Surah
3 that has anything to do, positive or
negative, with the previous scriptures.
I didn't even highlight verse 7 because
it doesn't say one word about the
previous verse seven is clarifying verse
verse three, man. Yeah, but verse seven
is saying all is from our Lord. All
means all the books.
So that actually helps us, not you. I I
wanted to bring this up and then we're
gonna move on. Man, I'm just saying
these are all the verses, right, that
Jai and Gio have found where it talks
about confirming previous scriptures.
They found 18 of them and they know
Arabic. Please explain to me how 37
applies to all of these verses and not a
single one of these verses that clearly
say it's confirming our previous
scriptures. How apparently it's all
unclear. Please explain that to me. I
don't know. I read this. Okay, you don't
know you guys with the Quran. I don't
know. You see, the thing is is we've
just this this alone is 18 different
verses that that advocate for our case
incredibly strongly. It's clear as day.
18 verses in the Arabic. You can't you
can't do a single one and you've gone to
37 as a defense for 33. So, so, so 33 is
one of our main verses that we use.
Yeah. Guys, let me let me read
for anyone who does. Yeah, 33 is on the
list. It's right there. So, surah 3:3,
ladies and gentlemen, I'll I'll read the
beginning. I'll read verse four as well
because it's is connected. He sent down
the book upon thee, Muhammad in truth,
confirming what was before it. And he
sent down the Torah and the Gospel of
four time as a guidance to mankind. And
he sent down the criterion. So he sent
down it's confirming what was before it.
And again, this is not confirming what
is before it in time. It's
confirming what is between hands. It's
in its presence. So I mean, just imagine
this. You're going to a verse and we're
saying where does the Quran say that the
previous scriptures are corrupt and you
say surah 3:3 it's right there and we go
to surah 3:3 and he says I'm confirming
the book that is in the presence of the
Quran as it's being revealed you are
saying the exact opposite of what Allah
says and if we say my goodness this
verse is as clear as day you go aha few
verses later it says things in the Quran
are unclear so what are you going to do
anytime you find something in the Quran
that you disagree with or you don't like
or you reject or that goes against what
your dawa guy says, you say, "Oh, that's
one of the unclear verses." I already
told you, your scholars have dealt with
this issue because the Quran like a
beating drum over and over again says
that it's clear. And then you get to
3:7, which is a response to Christians
who wre havoc on Muhammad by pointing
out all the theological problems in the
Quran because he adopted all these
things that don't fit in with Islam. And
then you say, how do Muslim scholars
reconcile this? They say, "Oh, this is
for theological things that we can't
understand. They're beyond our
understanding." What is the clear part?
The clear part are the cor are are are
the commands. Well, guess what? We are
commanded to judge by the gospel. Jews
are commanded to judge by the Torah. So,
if Allah does not mean those things,
then he's not clear, even on the parts
that are supposed to be the clearest of
the clear, which would mean that the
Quran just isn't clear at all. Isa,
look, check this out, man. Rewatch this
discussion. Re-watch this discussion.
Reflect on this. And, you know, you're
welcome back anytime. You've been
respectful. You're cool. So, come back
anytime. We could talk about this again.
And um you know I like to see what
you've done on reflection. Okay. All
right. Sound good. That'd be good. Take
care, bro. God bless you, man.